One of the problems that Bit Torrent needs
to solve is ensuring that each client gets chunks
to swap with other clients. If all the
clients received the same chunks, then no-one would want
to trade with one another and everyone would
have an incomplete copy of the file. To solve
this problem, Bit Torrent clients use a policy
called rarest piece first. Rarest piece first allows a
client to determine which pieces are the most
rare among clients, and download the rarest pieces
of the file first. This ensures that the
most common pieces are left til the end to
download, and that a large variety of pieces
are downloaded from the seeder. Additionally, a client has
nothing to trade and it's important to get
a complete piece as soon as possible. Rare pieces
are typically available at fewer peers initially. Downloading a
rare piece is initially maybe not a good idea.
So one policy that clients use is to select
a random piece of the file and download it
from a seeder. In the end game the client
actively requests any missing pieces from all peers, and
redundant requests are cancelled when the missing piece arrives.
This ensures that a single peer with the slow transfer
rate doesn't prevent the download from completing.